Căng thẳng giữ Xerén bà Irang leo thẳng nghiêm trọng trong những ngày qua khiến cộng đồng của tế lo ngạn
Wico Bung Nộ mùl của trên trang trung đồng toàn diet.
Tại hôm nay, gửi gửi bà y ziễn giả, các nha ra,
có lấy đạo thần rồi đưa ra và đề này lên hàng đầu, chương trình nghĩa sự.
Súng đột mà màn bằng việc Xerén mở được tận công chốc nhỏ không thể sấu,
nhằm vào các cơ sử hành nhân và bộ tri威 quân sự hàng đầu của Irang.
Khiến bầu trời tế Xerén bốc trái trong lêng.
Đông thái này làm giả dầu brand tong mạnh, người thêm bất oàn cho kinh tế toàn cầu.
Mí, nông mình quan trọng quý Xerén khẳng đing,
không thăm ra trực tiếp và chính dịch,
nhưng đã hỗ trợ Xerén đánh chạp tế lửa.
Tổng thống mí đường năng trăm ngoài ra cùng căng ở chính dịch quý Xerén
và cạnh bảo Irang không được mở giống phạm vi trả đưa thêm nữa.
Ngàym đông thằng sau, 2 quan trưng Mỹ thậm chí tiếp lộ tổng thủ đường Năng Trâm đã nhận được đề sốt của Yerén.
Nhằm âm sát lãnh tủ tôi gạo Irang ở Aia Tổ la khảm y lay,
tùy bay tổng trăm đã báo bỏ ý tưởng này.
Về phy Irang, lúc này tuyên bố sẽ mở cạnh tổng địa ngục để đáp trả và tư cho mọi đề sốt đảm phán trong lúc bị tấn công.
Một quan trức tiếp lộ về Rồi Tư rằng,
Tế Irang đã thông bảo với các nước chung ra như cà ta và uan rằng,
chỉ xem sẽ đối thoại sau khi đạo hoàn tất phản công
và Icerran Khung còn trên khai mất kỳ hành động của sự nào nữa.
Trong bước cảnh đó, tụi tưởng nước ông Friedrich Moskker gọi kìm chế,
ngăn Irang, sau hiệu quốc gia đean, đàn bảo quyền tử về của Icerran và tạo cơ hội trong ngoại giao.
Tổng thống trăm trước thêm hộ nghĩa vào bài cũng bài tỏ hi vang sẽ đạt được một thảo thất,
nhưng thường nhật, lúc khi họ phải đến nhau một chặt mới có thể đi đến đàn phán.
Súng lộ Icerran Irang đang nhé trong vượt dàng ngoài khuôn khổ,
hãy của gia kéo theo hệ lịch quân sự, ngoại giao và kinh tệ tọn gầu,
và những người gơ hiện hiểu của một của trên lớn ở chúng đau.